so how do you change one thing when that
one thing
is everything you have to do it one
breath at a time
you have to do it one thing at a time
one hour at a time one day at a time and
you have to bring to that experience a
certain presence an intentionality a
focus placed squarely on just trying to
make a better choice every time a
decision is presented to you beginning
with the smallest most mundane low-risk
decisions that greet you every day
building from there
most days are one step forward one step
back some are no steps forward two steps
back
but every once in a while you get one
step forward and no steps back a brick
laid on the foundation
and tomorrow
another opportunity